When gardening and caring for onions and garlic,
there is sometimes confusion on what exactly
to do.
For garlic, we always want to top the plants
to help build the bulbs.
For onions, however, we do not want to cut
or top them.
If we find onions in our garden that look
similar to these, with flowers, we want to
pull them immediately.
If we have onions that have not flowered,
we want them to continue growing naturally
until the stalks have fallen over by themselves.
We’ll want to make sure to pull them out
on a hot, dry sunny day like we have today.
Once we have pulled the onions, we’ll want
to leave the stalks on and let them cure naturally
in a cool, dry place for two to three weeks.
After that time, we’ll then want to cut
the stalks about one to two inches above the
bulb, and then we can use them for storage.
We’ll want to store the healthy onions by
themselves, avoiding any damaged or diseased
onions with the healthy ones.
Some varieties may last two to three months,
while others many only last one to two weeks.
From the University of Wyoming Extension,
I’m Brian Sebade, and you’re watching
From the Ground Up.